is the morning here on Valentine's Day
just got out of a really intense awesome
really great actually client meeting
that's a lot of fun and so always
amazing to have super smart clients and
sauna on ideation now has back to the
office for a bunch of meetings cuz
everybody's having a great day and tear
on Blackwell way I'm Tom Geisel
around like a visible and I see with
clarity hi my name is Gabby Tom but I've
been telling you accountability
i'm tripoli given a pedigree I mean
enough pressure my fantasy 20 the work
that I'm doing are the moving furniture
7 hey good yeah good to see you
hey rose ah we're about to do this yeah
what's the name of the podcast ah the
journal oh the journal yeah well it
under the journal Ryan did it suck the
children what oh yeah Hoover yeah he did
it do you reckon even oh yeah living
life yeah
alright let's get started Gary Vee yes
sir it is good to have you it's good to
be here man
why vaynermedia what made you think well
I think you remember this like and I
don't you know I think it's actually
more interesting to ask you because and
I don't know if you'll remember I don't
know if it's enough of a moment for you
to remember and it's a long time ago but
I thought everybody our whole crew
Sock'em or in Travis everybody was
weirded out that AJ and I started
vaynermedia because everybody was
building big tech apps and raising tons
of money actually I was alerted out by
it at all because you're practical well
I to that point you're proactive or
spring what I knew was I was building a
foundation for my future
it wasn't hard for me the first 13 years
of my life once sexy I was quiet and I
built an actual business but how did you
get funding next Sheryl no no we landed
a Gillette project for $80,000 we
activated a Vegas
Travis flew in and slept on our home in
Asia as you
I met this dude at a Nets game who had
an agency with a subcontract track today
and he's like hey like would you know
your start I was like he said what are
you doing you're the wine guy I'm like
no no I'm starting a thing called
vaynermedia really talk to this point
you were gaining some popularity and I
was writing crush it correct
this started in May of 2009 that came
out in October so just finish reading
that and I just gave a head read that
yet no and I just gave that web 2.0 top
everybody has time
stop watching [ __ ] lost my whole
world up so that was that was good
no no that's the moment okay there's two
moments being on big nation with you and
I'll 100% I love that you guys are like
you guys are like in in press mode with
your little Madonna Talk
I look cute why do you like a shadow
Jack what is goes that combo there were
three or four months apart really put me
in a place what are people having a hard
time figuring out that you wish you
could just like really tell people like
this is what you need to succeed I mean
people looking to you for like that
thing to tip them over mission either
permission permission people are scared
to fail you know one thing you and I
have well I usually just be me I was
about to say the one thing you and I
have in common and our differences is
that you are so not scared to get your
eyes it just but like we'll all be dust
in like 30 years if you know I better
not dying 30 years the craziest guy
thank you pinkies better kiss Tommy I'm
just saying like why not man like why
not give it your all and just go crazy
do people care what other people think
who cares everyone's going to feel
you're gonna pick up cool I'm gonna fail
of course like everywhere we look around
at people just still trying to sing or
definitely it's a man being on the show
thank you very much all right that was
fun brah get together and just kind of
shoot the [ __ ] you know like feel like
it's a feel like I'm doing a lot of
one-on-ones and you know mmm I still
haven't really putting up Sonny was
thinking about it today without agree
remembering that we were doing this
today like just like why don't we can
hide you the townhall thing but even if
I can finally figure my [ __ ] out and do
the townhall thing I want to do more of
these 1520's I just don't think I think
what's holding me back is I just don't
see
we're going to get anything real with
700 people you know tough to ask those
questions that you really want an answer
from but I'm trying to figure out how to
scale a little bit because people are
not I mean when I look around the room
here and think about how little time
I've had with some of you like that's
exactly why I'm here I think my style of
building businesses is to establish
kindness and culture first and so I
think about it like parenting Thank You
parent your kids in the first three or
four years and from most of you somebody
will get this opportunity very different
than me she is perfectly aligned with
the age of this company they were
literally born the same month right I
expect a little more from Misha than we
do from Xander so she's seven and he 4
do you think if you didn't get something
you guys with angel nothing will you
been doing differently no because it's
how a library so you think like nothing
but timing lines do you think you'd be
able to do a lot of the giving back than
you doing now at this scale yeah it's
the thing that I did a tub in one
library
I'm just patient with what's everybody
in rush for look I promise you if I you
ask everybody hey if you want to make
ten million dollars in three years but
you want to make fifty million dollars
and 11 I mean we'll take the famine
three that's fine but I don't know I
like the 1511 I think people get
confused and unfortunately this document
this at the time so so there's something
interesting I was about to say I think
people get confused cuz I wasn't
documenting my life and thoughts when I
was actually being patient in my 20s and
now they see it well I don't think
people realize it I'm not getting
compared to what I'm going to be so when
I'm gonna be the guy it's like these not
nice cult status amongst the smart
homies then this is gonna be interesting
this will be real interesting when you
know when I sell a company for 1.7
billion is really really interesting
when I buy a brand and flip it this
would be really interesting when I make
my I know that I have another Facebook
and uber in me like when I make that but
I'm going to put five million into it at
a ten million dollar valuation on half
of it and then this is gonna be
interesting in 25 years
what other things like that so I think
in the tech world or for all my career
but I have a lot of friends I always ask
whether or not I was that round thing
putting my post yeah like the enemy and
desire to do your own thing today you
have such a confidence kind of vibe but
make sense but it's funny because my
answer was always so like I I think I'm
very and until you put it in your
content I think it really stuck with me
like I'm not very good I get him in I
think I think they love you right back
so I'm going to say something that
pisses me off with the rock just
catching this because I said it here and
there but I don't think I don't think
I'm gonna be a big scaping this one I
secretly wish I was number two it's the
best job you get you get a lot of the
economics a lot you get a lot a lot a
lot of the perks and a lot less of the
[ __ ] you're still number two when you're
number one your professional gannis when
you're number one you're in the
shittiest spot ever
you got it devastates me that my
hardwiring forced me into the narrative
I am obsessed with number two its Doug
its Z did it just quaint you looking
impact you can just so much and there's
just still something about not being the
last line of defense
you still get to look at somebody else
and go yeah and and for me for me the
way I am theoretically I will show her
number two but for me like even it's so
funny even though I just made that huge
rant like I could never look at somebody
and say what I'm gonna do you know it's
funny but it's a good gig it's
everything and I think and I think even
more interestingly I think number three
in Florence I mean if you are if you can
be impactful there's people my company
that are number 57 but have a lot of
influence and that's a really great gig
you know but that's everything really
that's right yeah that's right that's
right
the 6-2 at Facebook
willingly oh my god
more money from a financial standpoint
number 52 at Facebook is going to make
more than 99.9% of number one that's why
I always remind people that interact
with me it's where I think New Rock is
very smart and watching his whole
narrative like you gotta be smart when
you catch a tiger by the tail
you really did it first thing she just
told you think they notice us being on
the rock ship sailing yeah right right
right uh-huh you just take with these
with every gift given to you and I loved
that I loved the meritocracy of it all
look the people that jump off my ship
I'm such a son of a [ __ ] when it comes
to the competitive nature of business
like I love them and I feel sad and I
want nothing but great and I genuinely
genuinely genuinely wish they'd go on
and do bigger but if they stayed with me
I really I really do
however I'm excited too knowing that
that's probably not going to be the case
and I can't wait to see them that's why
I love business because you can be a
good guy and you can be an assassin at
the same time and if you know how to
balance it you can really pull it off
actually down like 2030
I'm going to take the mic off for now
dear
[Music]
you